สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมนะคะครู
เรียมคะวันนี้เดี๋ยวครูเอ๋แชร์จะกินก่อน
ดีกว่าเนาะ
ได้ค่ะ
วันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะ
วันเสาร์นะคะใช่แล้ววันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 24 ค่ะวันที่ 24 นะคะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมปี
พ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะ
[เพลง]
ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
2022 นะคะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้
10 โมง
25 นาทีค่ะ
10:25 นนะคะเราก็จะคุยกันจนถึงกี่โมงคะ
จนถึง 10 โมง
55 นาที 55 นาทีนะคะ
ครูเอ๋ลบตรงนี้ก่อนนะคะลบลบลบลบลบลบออก
หมดแล้ว
วันนี้วันที่ 24
วันอะไรคะครูเรียว
วันวันพรุ่งนี้ใช่ไหมวันนี้วันนี้แล้วก็
พุ่ง
วันนี้บ้านอีฟ
เห็น background ของครูเอ๋
และก็เอาของครูเอกเป็นรูปอะไรคะ
[เพลง]
มีดาว
ใช่ไหมมีเทียน
มี
อันนี้เป็นแฟนต้าเทียนมีตะเกียงอ่า
เป็นครูเอ๋ไปถ่ายรูปมาจากไหนจำไม่ได้
ต้องเป็นอะไรนะ
เป็น background เป็นคริสต์มาสครูเอ๋เห็น
ครูเรียนใส่อะไรคะ
ติดกิ๊บ
ติดเกมติดกิ๊บเป็นหมวกเป็นรูปหมวก
สีอะไรคะ
หมวกสีแดงสีแดงแล้วก็มีมีกลมๆเรียกว่า
อะไร
กลมๆสีขาว
แล้วก็สี
สีอะไรอีกมีสีเขียว
เป็นวิ้งใช่
เวลาขยับก็จะวิ้งๆๆ
สวยนะคะเอามาติดผมค่ะ
ใช่
โอเคเราเอง
ล่ะคะเออ
มี background แล้วก็ทาปากแดง
สีแดงโชคดีใช่มั้ยโชคดี
ค่ะสีแดงคือครูเอ๋จะทาปากสีแดงนิดหน่อยนะ
คะวันนี้ทาสีแดงมากแดงๆนักเรียนมองเห็น
ชัดๆเลยเพราะว่าแดงมาก
ปากสีแดงมากนะคะ
โอเคค่ะวันนี้นะคะก็เดี๋ยวกลับไปดูที่
สกรีนของเราได้เลยค่ะ 25 นะคะพรุ่งนี้ 25
แล้วก็มะรืนนี้ 26
มะรืนนี้วันต่อไป 27  28
อีกกี่วันนะคะ
1  2  3  4  5  6  7 อีก 7 วันค่ะ
อีก 7 วันก็จะ
ปีใหม่
ปีใหม่แล้วงั้นปีใหม่ปีใหม่นี้ปีอะไรคะ
คุณเอกปี
2566 ค่ะมองเห็นไหมผู้เรียนมองเห็นนะมอง
เห็นค่ะมองเห็นปีหน้าปีหน้า
2566 ก็อีก 7 วันนะคะปีเก่าปีนี้ก็จะ
เป็นปีเก่า
เราก็จะขึ้นปีใหม่ตอนนี้เนี่ยช่วงตั้งแต่
จนถึง
ตั้งแต่ 24 จนถึง 31 เราเรียกว่า
สิ้นเดือนใช่ไหมคะสิ้นเดือนธันวาคมนะคะ
[เพลง]
สิ้นเดือนธันวาคมแล้วก็เรียกว่าช่วงนี้
เป็นช่วงอะไรคะปลาย
ปีปลายปีปลายปีอะไรคะ
ปลายปี
2565 ตอนนี้เป็นปลายปี 2565
[เพลง]
พอเดือนมกราคม
เดือนมกราคมนะคะถ้าเป็นวันที่ 1 เนี่ยก็
คือปีใหม่นะคะปีใหม่
5 วันที่ 31 ธันวาคมก็
วันปีเก่า
แต่ถ้าเกิดเป็นแบบช่วงนี้ 24-25  26  27
28  29  30  31 ก็จะพบว่าปลายปีนะคะบาง
ทีอาจจะเป็น 1 เดือนก็ได้ปลายปี
ก็ 31 เลย
แต่ว่าถ้าเป็นเดือนมกราคมใช่ไหมคะ
เดือนมกราคมถึงกุมภาพันธ์
เราก็บอกว่าต้นปี
เป็นต้นๆของปีเราจะมีต้นปีกลางปีแล้วก็
ปลายปีนะคะปลายปีงั้นเนี่ยตอนนี้ก็
ปลายปีแล้วใช่ไหมคะอ่า
ทีนี้
พอสิ้นปีปุ๊บตรงนี้ก่อน
สิ้นปีก็คือวันที่ 3
แล้วจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นคะครูเอ๋
ถ้าเป็นครูเอ๋เด็กๆก็นอนไม่มีอะไร
แต่ว่าพอโตๆขึ้นใช่ไหมปีใหม่
ปีใหม่เนี่ยโตขึ้นแบบประมาณอายุเท่าไหร่
ที่ครูเอ๋แบบตื่นเต้นปีใหม่ 13
เนี่ย Happy
Birth อายุ 13 ปีดีใจเพราะ 13 ปีมา
กรุงเทพฯก็ปีใหม่แต่ก่อน 13 น่ะเอ้ยไม่สน
ใจปีใหม่
ทีนี้ปีใหม่เนี่ยก็ต้องมีคำอวยพร
คำอวยพรแบบไหนนะที่แบบครูเอกพูดบ่อยๆ
คือ
คำอวยพรมีหลายๆอย่างที่ครูเอ๋พูดคำอวยพร
คืออะไร
คำอวยพร
คำอวยพรก็คือคำพูดหรือว่าที่เราเขียนใช่
ไหมเขียนเขียนก็ได้เขียนอ่า
ถ้าเป็นของนักเรียนก็สวัสดีปี
ใหม่
เราพูดว่าสวัสดีปีใหม่
นะคะ
คำอวยพรก็จะพูดหรือเขียนก็ได้ที่แบบพูดดี
ๆเขียนดีๆให้คนอื่น
ใช่ไหมคะใช่ก็อันนี้ค่ะสวัสดีปีใหม่ภาษา
อังกฤษเราไม่อ่านเนาะเพราะเราต้องพูดภาษา
ไทยเราก็พูดเป็นภาษาไทยว่าสวัสดีปีใหม่นะ
คะ
สวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีปีใหม่
เพราะวันนี้วันคริสต์มาสแต่สวัสดีปีใหม่
วันนี้ครูเรียนกับครูเอ๋ก็จะมาพูดถึงคำ
อวยพรของไทยนักเรียนฟังดีๆนะเมื่อกี้ครู
เรียมถามครูเอ๋ว่า
คำอวยพรที่ใช้บ่อยๆอะไรใช่ไหมคะ
ก็จะเป็นภาษาที่ฟังง่ายสำหรับคนไทยนิดนึง
สำหรับนักเรียนอาจจะฟังยากนิดนึง
แต่มันก็มีภาษาแบบยากแล้วก็ง่ายง่ายนะคะ
เอากลางๆเนาะครูเอกก็จะพูดว่า
1 คือสวัสดีปีใหม่
ง่ายๆนะ
สวัสดีปีใหม่สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูเอกก็
จะพูดสวัสดีปีใหม่นะคะสวัสดีปีใหม่แบบนี้
แล้วก็สวัสดีปีใหม่ขอให้
ขอให้ครูเรียมสุขภาพแข็งแรง
ขอบคุณค่ะสวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะครูเอ๋
ขอให้ครูเอ๋สุขภาพแข็งแรงเหมือนกันค่ะ
เวลาที่เขาเขียนใช่ไหมอันที่ 1 เลยสวัสดี
ปีใหม่ขอให้สุขภาพแข็งแรงสุขภาพก็คือร่าง
กายเนาะให้แข็งแรงคิด
โอเคต้องแชร์สกินอีกแล้ว
ได้เลย
คิดใช่ไหมคะ
หรือสมองเนาะ
แล้วก็คิดคิด
เขาบอกว่าคิดอะไร
คิดอะไร
ขอให้ขอให้สมปรารถนา
[เพลง]
ปรารถนาก็คืออยากได้
ปรารถนาก็คืออยากได้ครูเรียนอยากได้อะไร
คะ
อยากได้รถ 1 คัน
อยากได้รถใช่ไหมครูเรียนอยากได้รถ
รถอะไรคะ
อยากได้
[เพลง]
หนังสือ
อยากได้หนังสือ
อยากได้อะไรอีกอยากได้บ้างอยากได้บ้าน
ใหญ่ขึ้น
หรือเล็ก
ใหญ่ขึ้นอยากได้บ้านใหญ่ขึ้นบ้านเล็กมี
แล้วโอเคอยากได้บ้านใหญ่
อยากได้อะไรอีก
อยากได้
โทรศัพท์ใหม่อะไรคะอยากได้โทรศัพท์
อยากได้อะไรอีก
อยากได้อะไรอีกอ่ะ
อยากได้ยอด Subscribe เท่าไหร่ใช่อยากได้
ยอด Subscribe เพิ่มอีกนะคะที่ช่องไหนคะ
[เพลง]
อยากได้ยอด Subscribe เท่าไหร่อยากได้ยอด
ซับเซอร์ไพรส์
2,000 ทรัพย์
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
นะคะนักเรียนกด Subscribe นะคะ
ขอบคุณล่วงหน้า
อยากได้ก็อยากเราก็จะอวยพรว่าคิด
อะไรนะคิดอยากได้อะไรใช่ไหมคะเขาจะบอกว่า
คิดอะไร
ขอให้สมปรารถนา
หรือบางทีเขาก็พูดสั้นๆว่าขอให้สุขภาพ
แข็งแรงสมปรารถนา
คำว่าสมปรารถนาก็คือคิด
อะไรขอให้ได้สมปรารถนา
ปีใหม่ก็คือสวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะขอให้สุขภาพ
แข็งแรงคิดอะไรก็สมปรารถนานะคะอ่ามีความ
สุข
[เพลง]
มีความสุข
มีความสุขเวลาเรามีความสุขเรายิ้มใช่ไหม
คะใช่ค่ะก็ยิ้ม
นะคะก็มีความสุขทุกๆวันก็คือ 3 ไป 65 วัน
เนี่ย
มีความสุขทุกๆวัน
ว้าวดีมากๆขอบคุณค่ะ
อะไรนะขอให้แข็งแรง
คิดสิ่งใดคิดอะไรขอให้สมปรารถนา
มีความสุขทุกวัน
[เพลง]
มีอีกมีอีกมีอะไรอีกคะ
ครูเอ๋มีคำอวยพรเยอะมากๆ
อันนี้เป็นบันได
เวลาเราทำงานใช่ไหมคะทำงานเป็นครูหรือทำ
งานอะไรก็ได้เราก็อยากจะก้าวขึ้นอะไรนะมี
ขั้นที่ 1 ขั้นที่ 2 ขั้นที่ 3 ขั้นที่ 4
แล้วก็ตรงนี้
สำเร็จเขียนถูกไหมเนี่ย
เราก็ขอให้
ก้าวหน้า
ก้าวหน้าในการงาน
ก็คือทำงานแล้วก็ก้าวหน้า
มีอะไรนะมีเงินเดือนเงินใช่ไหมที่นี่เงิน
เดือนอาจจะเท่าไหร่ดี 30,000
30,000 ใช่ไหมคะเงินเดือนนี้ก็คือแบบ
เหมือน 30 วันก็จะได้รับเงินเดือนใช่ไหม
ใช่เงินเดือนก็ขึ้นๆๆเป็น 60,000 บาท
หรือว่าอาจจะมีก้าวหน้าอย่างอื่นอีกนะ
ตำแหน่งใช่
ถ้าเป็นครูเรียนกับครูเอ๋ก็เป็น
เป็นครูสอนออนไลน์ก็
Subscribe เยอะๆ
ก้าวหน้าหรือว่าทำงานเก่งขึ้นก้าวหน้า
[เพลง]
การงานก้าวหน้า
ใช่ๆ
เหมือนจะเป็นแบบพนักงานใช่ไหมคะก็ได้
เลื่อนขึ้นไปเป็นแบบเป็นอะไรนะ
คนไทยก็พูดนะ 4  e  o
เลื่อนขึ้นนะคะ
มีอะไรอีกนะมีสุขภาพแข็งแรงคิดอะไรสม
ปรารถนามีความสุขการงานก้าวหน้า
แคล้วคลาดจากอันตราย
[เพลง]
เป็นยังไงคะแล้วพลาด
แล้วพลาดเนี่ยหมายความว่า
อันตรายนะครูเรียนรู้จากอันตรายเนาะอะไร
ที่น่ากลัว
อะไรที่ทำให้เราเจ็บเนี่ย
แคล้วคลาดคือไม่เจอ
สมมุติว่าที่นี่ใช่ไหมคะถนน
แล้วก็ตรงนี้มีภูเขา
แล้วก็
ฝนตก
ตรงนี้มีทางแยก
เดี๋ยวคุยอีกวัดใหม่ขอโทษ
เอาภูเขาออกก่อน
มีถนนมาที่นี่
ตรงนี้มีทางแยก
ตรงนี้ครูเรียมคิดจะไปที่นี่
ตรงนี้ใกล้ๆ
[เพลง]
ทาง a เนี่ย
ใกล้ทาง B เนี่ยไกล
นะคะขับรถอยู่ที่นี่
คิดจะไปตรงนี้
มีภูเขา
แล้วก็มีฝนตก
ฝนตก
ๆตกมากๆ
แล้วครูเรียมเลี้ยวผิดเลี้ยวไปทางนี้ไกล
แต่ทางนี้ใกล้คิดจะไปใกล้แต่
ซ้ายขวา
ไป
ขวาแต่ไกลนะ
ปรากฏว่าฝนตกมากๆ
ดินมัน
ถล่มลงมา
ที่ถนน
มีรถที่ไปทางนี้
ลดไปที่นี่ก็เจอดิน
อันตรายใช่ไหมคะ
แต่ครูเรียมเนี่ยไปทางทางขวาไปทางที่ไกล
ไกลแต่ไม่เจอกับดินถล่มอันนี้แคล้วคลาด
แบบนี้นี่เองที่ไหนแคล้วคลาดจากอันตราย
อันนี้อันตรายใช่ไหมดินถล่มน่ากลัวแต่ครู
เรียงไปขวา
ขวาเนี่ยไกล
ทำไมมาขวา
แต่เสร็จแล้วคนที่ไปซ้ายน่ะเจอดินถล่มไง
แต่เราไม่เจอก็พูดว่าแคล้วคลาดเวลาอวยพร
ปีใหม่เราก็จะพูดจบด้วยแคล้วคลาดจาก
อันตรายทั้งหมด
เวลาครูเอกอวยพรปีใหม่ใช่ไหมก็จะอวยพรว่า
ขอให้สุขภาพแข็งแรง
ใช่ไหมคะ
ก็สมปรารถนาปรารถนาปรารถนาคือคิดอยากได้
สมปรารถนา
มีความสุข
ทุกๆวันนะคะ
การงานก้าวหน้า
แล้วก็แคล้วคลาดจากอันตราย
[เพลง]
ครูเอ๋แบบมีคำอวยพรดีๆเยอะมากๆแต่ว่าแบบ
ครูเอ๋มีคำอวยพรแบบอย่างอื่นอีกไหมยังไม่
ได้มีเกี่ยวกับครอบครัวความรักเลยนะ
[เพลง]
ถ้าเป็นเพื่อนแล้วยังไม่มีแฟน
ขอให้ปีนี้เจอหนุ่มหล่อ
[เพลง]
หนุ่มก็คือผู้ชาย
ชอบผู้ชายยังไงคะตาโตจมูกโด่ง
หล่อตาโตจมูกโด่งผมยาวผมสั้น
ผมสั้นซิกแพคใช่
โอเค
ใจดีไหม
ใจดี
โอเคงั้นขอให้ครูปีใหม่นี้ขอให้ครูเรียม
มีแฟนหล่อใจดีฉลาด
ขอบคุณค่ะ
แล้วสำหรับคนที่แต่งงานแล้วล่ะ
แต่งงานเรียบร้อยแล้ว
เขาแต่งงานส่วนใหญ่ก็จะอวยพรแบบนี้แหละ
ค่ะสุขภาพแข็งแรงแต่ถ้าแต่งงานแล้วยังไม่
มีลูกก็ขอให้ปีใหม่นี้มี
สมาชิกก็คือมีลูก
เพิ่มขึ้นนะคะ
ขอให้คิดอะไรก็สมปรารถนา
ก็คิดอยากมีลูกใช่ไหม
แม่ลูกคิดอยากจะมีลูกก็ขอให้มีลูก
จะเห็นว่าคิดอะไรแล้วสมปรารถนานี้ก็คือ
รวมทุกอย่างแล้วใช่คิดอะไรได้คิดอะไรแล้ว
ก็สมปรารถนา
ใช่ไหมคะ
ปกติครูเรียมอวยพรปีใหม่ว่ายังไง
เรียนก็อวยพรปีใหม่ว่าสวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะขอ
ให้สุขภาพแข็งแรง
แล้วก็มีเงิน
ทองไหลมา
เทมา
เหมือนฝนตกเลยใช่ไหม
เหมือนแม่น้ำ
ริมทองไหลมาเทมาแล้วก็คิดอะไร
ก็ขอให้ได้
สิ่งที่คิด
[เพลง]
ก็ครบทุกอย่างแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋หรือง่ายๆง่าย
ๆก็ได้นะคะนักเรียนไม่รู้จะอวยพรอะไรไม่
รู้พูดอะไรครูเอ๋พูดยากจังเลยขอให้ร่าง
กายแข็งแรงคิดสิ่งใดคิดอะไรขอให้สม
ปรารถนามีความสุขทุกวันอะไรอีกนะการงาน
ก้าวหน้าแคล้วคลาดจากอันตรายอู้ยาว
เหนื่อยง่ายๆเลยค่ะทำยังไงสวัสดีปีใหม่ขอ
ให้มีความสุข
ยิ้มต้องมีความสุขมากๆ
ค่ะ
ง่ายๆนะใช่มีความสุขมากๆจบแล้ว
หรือบางคนอาจจะพูดแค่สวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะ
สวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดี
ปีใหม่ค่ะ
[เพลง]
ก็ได้นะคะสวัสดีปีใหม่เอ๊ะแต่ว่าวันนี้
เนี่ย
เป็นวันคริสต์มาสใช่ไหมใช่
เราสวัสดีปีใหม่ละยังไม่สวัสดีวัน
คริสต์มาสเลยคุณเอ๋มีคำอวยพรวันคริสต์มาส
ไหม
เหมือนกันไหม
เหมือนกันนะ
เพราะคนศาสนาพุทธใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋อวยพรแบบ
ศาสนา
คริสต์ไม่เป็นก็จะอวยพรว่าสวัสดีวัน
คริสต์มาสขอให้
มีสุขภาพแข็งแรง
นะคะที่หนึ่งเลยสุขภาพแข็งแรง
มีความสุขมากๆ
แล้วก็สาว
ทำอะไรอะไรก็ได้นะคะถ้าเรียนหนังสือก็
เรียนเก่งๆ
ถ้าเรียนทำงานก็ทำงานเก่งๆ
ใช่
แต่งงานอยากจะมีลูกก็ขอให้มีลูกแข็งแรง
ทั้งหมดตรงนี้ก็คือ
ขอให้สำเร็จคิดอะไรก็สำเร็จอยากเรียนเก่ง
ก็เก่งอยากจะมีลูกก็มีลูกอยากจะมีแฟนก็มี
แฟนเราบอกว่าสำเร็จคิดอะไรก็ให้สำเร็จทุก
ๆอย่าง
แล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะวันคริสต์มาสได้อวยพร
หรือว่าพูดสิ่งดีๆให้คนอื่นๆยาวเหมือนครู
เอ๋ไหม
จริงๆมันสั้นนะแต่ว่าครูเอ๋อธิบายยาวสั้น
ง่ายๆก็คืออะไรอ่ะ
สวัสดีวันคริสต์มาสขอให้แข็งแรงนะคะมี
ความสุขสำเร็จทุกประการ
แล้วถ้าเกิดแบบเรียนนะแบบอวยพรแบบสั้นๆ
เรียนเจอครูเอ๋เรียนก็จะบอกว่า
คริสต์มาสค่ะ
[เพลง]
ทุกคนค่ะ
สวัสดีวันคริสต์มาสค่ะ
สวัสดีวันคริสต์มาสค่ะขอให้มีความสุขนะคะ
นักเรียน
โอเคเดี๋ยวเราอวยพรให้ครูเรียมอวยพรจริงๆ
ให้กับนักเรียนวันคริสต์มาสกับปีใหม่ค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะอวยพรสำหรับวันคริสต์มาสแล้วก็ปี
ใหม่แบบเอามารวมกันเลยนะ
ก็ขอให้ครูเอ๋แล้วก็นักเรียนทุกคนนะคะมี
ความสุขมีความสุขมากๆยิ้มเยอะๆทุกๆวัน
แล้วก็สุขภาพแข็งแรงค่ะ
คิดอะไรก็ขอให้ได้สิ่งนั้น
ค่ะโอเคสวัสดีปีใหม่และ Merry  Christmas
ค่ะ
และสุขสันต์วันคริสต์มาสสุขสันต์วัน
คริสต์มาสคำว่าสุขสันต์ก็ได้
เราไม่ได้พูดว่าสุขสันต์
สุขสันต์ก็คือมีความสุข
นะคะสุขสันต์วันคริสต์มาสสุขสันต์วันปี
ใหม่นะคะ
[เพลง]
นักเรียนทุกคน
สุขสันต์วันคริสต์มาสค่ะ
ขอให้นักเรียนทุกคนเรียนภาษาไทย
เก่งๆ
ฟังภาษาไทยมากๆฟังแล้วก็พูดได้แบบ
automatic พูดได้เหมือนคนไทย
ขอให้
ครูทุกคน
มีสุขภาพครูทุกคนแล้วก็นักเรียนด้วยนะคะ
มีสุขภาพแข็งแรงนะคะแข็งแรงมีความสุขทุกๆ
วันนะคะแล้วก็ปีหน้านักเรียนมาคุยภาษาไทย
กับครูนะคะได้เลยนักเรียน
แต่ว่าวันนี้คลิปนี้นะคะเป็นยังไงคะครู
เอ๋หมดเวลาแล้วค่ะเราก็ต้องไปแล้ว
ก่อนจากไปก็สุขสันต์วันคริสต์มาสนะคะสุข
สันต์วันคริสต์มาสค่ะทุกคนไปแล้วนะคะ
สวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะสวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะนักเรียนหากนักเรียนบ๊าย
บายสวัสดีค่ะ